frustrated when you're angry or
frustrated what comes out whatever it is
it's a good indication of what you're
made of I'm frustrated with my business
constantly I want things to move faster
results are coming more quickly goals to
be achieved right now sometimes I have
to take a deep breath and remind myself
it's okay that's part of life as an
entrepreneur the most successful
entrepreneurs see the world differently
you see it as it could be not as it is
you have a vision from what you want and
it's easy to get frustrated when it
takes longer than expected for it to
happen it's natural I'm frustrated I
want to help a billion entrepreneurs I
want more people to visit my website
more people to watch my youtube videos
more people to listen to my radio show
and so on because I want you to reach
your potential as an entrepreneur and a
billion other people just like you I
don't want you to have to close down and
go get a job it's changing lives this
morning I was in the shower and all I
could think of was why is this taking so
long everyone has it every entrepreneur
gets frustrated a lot with their
business it's a love-hate relationship
and you've got to love what you're doing
enough to pull you through that all the
tough times hang in there I know that
you're not alone in this everyone from
your local dry cleaner or pizza shop up
to Bill Gates and Donald Trump gets
frustrated the bigger the goal you're
trying to accomplish the greater the
impact you want to have the more
resistance and more frustration you're
going to face keep going options if
you're feeling frustrated with your
business here are some options number
one model success look at people who
have done what you're trying to do
understand how hard it was for them I
learned what they did to overcome it
number two remember why you're doing
this this always works for me I remember
the entrepreneurs I'm trying to help and
the good it's going to do in the world
think of the people you're going to help
and let that drive you to keep going
number three use frustration as fuel
frustration can either drive you to quit
and give up or to make you stronger and
want it even more frustration is a
powerful emotion use it to create
something great I am you can to believe